힘이 들어서 슈카센 말한다 그랬더니 또 유치원 만들었다고. 아주 그냥 뽑아먹으려고. 질문이 뭡니까? 질문이.
비싼 주식이 더 좋은 주식입니까? 가격이 높으면 좋은 주식이냐고. 삼성전자가 지금 27만원인가? 하이닉스가 한 160 얼마죠? 하이닉스가 좋은 주식이냐고?
가격이 높아야 아무나 못 사서 더 프리미엄이 붙잖아요. 아 이거는 럭셔리. 이거는 서민 주식. 27만원. 국밥.
27,000원짜리는 내다 버린 주식 뭐 이런 건가? 편의점에서 볼 수 있는 주식. 편의점 주식. 시가총액이 뭔지는 알죠. 시가총액. 회사의 가치. 그게 이제 100만원짜리라고 봅시다.
100주가 있습니다. 그럼 한 주 가격 얼마예요? 만원. 이게 주가죠. 주식이 만주가 있어요. 한 주 가격은 얼마예요? 100만원? 충분하지 않게. 유치원입니다. 유치원이죠. 죄송합니다. 제가 그만 대학생들 상대하는 줄 알고.
근데 궁금한 게 있습니다. 시가총액은 주식에다가 프라이스를 곱하면 시가총액입니다.
아하. 그것도 또 알려주셔야 될 것 같습니다.
자 다시 할게요. 시가총액이라는 건 기업의 총가치예요. 기업은 주식이라는 걸로 이 기업의 주인을 정하잖아요. 주식을 100% 들고 있으면 100만원이 내게 되겠죠. 주식을 50% 들고 있으면 50만원이 내게 되겠죠.
자 그러니까 주식 총수가 회사마다 달라요. 100주로 돼 있는 회사가 시가총액이 100만원이면 이 한 주당 만원이겠죠. 자 만주로 나뉘어 있으면 한 주에 100원이겠죠. 두 개를 곱해야.
100만원이 되니까. 자 그러면 됐습니다. 자 그럼 여러분들이 질문한 건 이거잖아요. 만원짜리가 좋은 주식이냐? 100원짜리가 좋은 주식이냐?
만원짜리가 좋은 주식 아닙니까?
아니죠. 주식수에 따라서 달라지는 것이기 때문에 상관이 없습니다. 시가총액이 더 중요합니다.
자 그러면 오늘부터 초등학교로 가게.
예!
궁금한 게 있습니다. 주식수는 누가 정합니까?
이 회사가 주식을 발행할 때 결정할 수가 있어요. 예를 들면 시가총액이 100만원밖에 안 하는데 주식을 막 1억주 만들면 한 주에 1원도 안 될 거 아니에요. 0.1원?
막 이렇게 될 거니까. 회사의 크기에 따라서 적정 주식수가 바뀔 수 있죠. 한 주당 액면가라는 게 있어요.
아 이거 유치원에 하기 너무 어렵다.
어렵습니다.
이건 이제 이 회사의 자본금 기준으로. 아 이것도 어렵다.
주식을 처음 발행할 때 100원짜리로 만들 수도 있고 500원짜리로 만들 수도 있고 5000원짜리로 만들 수도 있어요.
액면가 얼마짜리 주식으로 발행할지를 결정할 수가 있어요.
이해하셨어요 다들?
액면가 처음 들어봤어요.
개미 입장에서는 안 중요한 거잖아요.
그러니까 이미 다 정해지고 나온 거라는 거잖아요.
중요하죠.
자 왜 중요한지도 얘기 드릴게요.
자 내가 이 얘기를 괜히 했어 액면가.
삼성전자가 지금 한 1500조 되나요? 예를 들면 이렇게 가정을 합시다. 얘가 한 1000조 되나?
27만원과 160만원을 딱 보면은 이게 비싸다고 좋은 게 아니라 당연히 주식수의 영향을 받겠죠. 이 위에 있는 이 시가총액. 기업의 모습을 당연히 봐야겠죠. 잘 이해했어요?
네.
예전에는 삼성전자가 SKX보다 훨씬 비쌌어요. 200만원이 넘어갔어요.
네? 진짜요?
200만원 넘어가니까 그때 무슨 얘기가 나왔냐면 너무 비싸서 못 사겠다. 그럼 어떻게 하면 돼요? 이 주식 한 줄을 50분의 1로 나눕니다. 그걸 액면 분할이라 그래요.
아 그래서 아까 액면가가 중요하다고 하신 거군요.
액면가 5000원짜리였어요. 그게 시장에서 거래를 200만원에 됐던 거예요. 근데 50분의 1로 나누면 어떻게 됩니까? 액면가가 이게 100원이 되죠.
100원에 50분의 1이 되니까 200만원짜리가 얼마가 됐어요?
200 나누기 50.
200만원.
200만원입니까? 200 나누기 50이?
100만원.
아니 200 나누기 50. 200 나누기 50.
4만원.
4만원이 됐어요. 죄송합니다. 아이들 앞에서는 화를 안 내려고 했는데. 자 그래서 이게 4만원이 된 거예요. 지금 이제 4만원이 가격이 올라서 27만원이 된 거죠. 50분의 1로 안쪽에 있으면 이거 얼마짜리입니까? 27만원 곱하기 원래 50을 해야 되잖아요.
네.
옛날 기준 한 줄은 1350인데 너무 비싸니까 이거를 50분 내려고 해서 여러분 지금 27만원에 거래를 하는 겁니다. 싸다고 안 좋고 비싸다고 좋은지 그런 게 아니라는 거죠.
어떤 분이 아까 그러셨어요. 그냥 합쳐서 크게 만들어 달라고. 그렇게 한 기업이 어디냐? sk하이닉스예요. sk하이닉스는 160만원이죠. 옛날에는 얼마였을까요? 125원이었어요.
125원이요?
그때 하이닉스였죠. 망한다고 얘기했던 때입니다. 회사가 너무 어렵고 왜냐 반도체 치킨게임 뭐 이런 거 해서 반도체 너무 어렵다.
이렇게 주가가 내려간 걸 무슨 주식이라 그럽니까?
동전주.
동전주. 자네는 잘하는구만 역시. 그래서 이거 안 되겠다. 여기는 액면 분할을 했잖아요. 삼성전자는 나눴어요. 얘는 합칩니다. 액면 병합을 해요.
그래서 120원짜리를 대충 20배로 합쳐서 한 3000원 이렇게 만든 겁니다.
그래도 싸다.
그게 지금 올라서 160만원으로 이제 가게 되는 겁니다. 그래서 삼성전자의 액면가 주식 한 주에 원래 액면에 있는 가격은 얼마라고요?
원이에요.
sk하이닉스는 액면에 있는 가격이 얼마입니까? 5000원인 겁니다.
액면가 5000원짜리를 사는 겁니다.
버블 아닙니까 그러면?
아니죠. 여기 100원이라는 거는 삼성전자가 처음 자본금 기준이니까 그 다음부터 돈 이만큼 벌었잖아요. 그러니까 이만큼의 확대가 된 거죠.
여러분 코스닥에 보면은 만원짜리 주식이 있고 예를 들면 코스피에 13000원짜리 주식이 있다고 봅시다.
코스닥에 삼성전자 있는 건가?
삼성전자는 코스피에 있어요. 코스피는 우리나라 큰 기업이 들어가는 데고 코스닥은 지금은 작은 약간 성장형 코넥스라는 데도 있어요.
그렇죠?
거기 이제 스타트업이 들어가는 데.
오케이. 만원짜리가 있고 13000원짜리가 있어요. 뭐가 더 비싸요?
13000원.
네. 일반적으로 그렇게 얘기할 수가 없어요.
코스닥에 들어가는 기업들은 액면가를 보통 500원 또는 100원으로 설정을 많이 합니다.
코스피에 들어갈 정도의 큰 기업들은 액면가가 5000원인 경우도 있어요.
액면가가 500원짜리가 만원 된 거는 몇 배예요? 20배죠.
500원짜리가 13000원 된 거는 몇 배입니까? 2.6배예요.
뭐가 더 비싸게 많이 올랐어요?
위에 거.
위에 게 많이 올랐지.
가격만 보고 이 기업이 더 큰 기업이야 라고 생각하면 안 된다는 거예요.
이 기업이 더 성장을 많이 했네 라고 생각하면 안 된다는 거예요.
자 그럼 여기서 한 걸음 더 나가볼까요? 왜 코스닥에 있는 작은 기업들은 주로 500원으로 할까요?
유리해서.
발행 주식 수를 많이 하려고?
여러분들 개인들이 보는 거는 여기는 주가란 말이에요.
주가가 적정하게 표시가 돼야 됩니다. 만약에 5000원으로 만들었다고 칩시다 얘네도.
근데 20배 되면 이게 얼마짜리가 돼요? 100000원짜리가 되잖아요.
너무 비싸지는군요.
그러면 사람들이 얘네들 왜 이렇게 비싸? 이렇게 생각해요. 잘 안 사.
전략적인 거네요 어떻게 보면.
전략적인 거죠. 여러분들한테 적절한 가격으로 보여야 거래가 잘 일어날 테니까.
그럼 저희가 투자할 때 액면가를 보는 게 좋나요? 안 보는 게 좋나요?
볼 수 있으면 보는 게 좋죠. 물론 이 액면가라는 게 모든 걸 표시하지는 않지만 자본금 기준으로 이 회사가 얼마나 성장을 했냐 이런 걸 볼 수도 있으니까.
제가 그거 굳이 말씀드린 이유는 주가만 보고 판단하면 안 된다는 겁니다.
그럼 저희가 투자를 할 때 주가 말고 봐야 될 게 아까 말씀 주신 시가총액이랑 주식 수를 보면 되나요?
정말 질문이 광범위하잖아요.
비싸냐 싸냐를 보려면 당연히 주가보다 시가총액을 봐야죠. 주식 수 시총이잖아요.
이 주식 수는 회사마다 달라요. 그러니까 여기 나온 가격을 보는 건 별로 의미가 없죠.
이게 보려는 거죠. 회사의 시가총액. 이 회사가 얼마나 크냐 작냐가 그 회사가 버블이냐 아니냐 싸냐 비싸냐를 결정하는 거니까 주식 수나 가격보다는 시가총액을 보는 게 적절하다라는 겁니다.
프라이스가 버블인지 아닌지는 어떻게 판단합니까?
저도 그게 궁금합니다.
항상 궁금했어요.
우리가 원래 이 기업이 비싼지 싼지는 이거를 보고 얘기를 하잖아요.
예를 들면 슈카칭구들이 100조야.
쌉니까? 비쌉니까?
비싸요.
안 비쌀 수도 있어요.
비싸잖아요.
그게 이 시가총액을 보고 얘기를 하는 거예요.
이걸 갖고 얘기하면 사람들이 잘 안 와다.
사람들이 많이 듣는 숫자는 이거란 말이에요.
삼성전자가 27만 원으로 우와 30만 원 우와 이러잖아요.
이것만 얘기해도 사실은 연동이 되어 있다는 거죠.
왜냐하면 뒤에 있는 총 주식 수는 상수니까.
이거는 잘 안 변해요.
이거는 우리가 흔히 유상증자나 가암자 같은 걸 하기 전에는 안 변하기 때문에
그러니까 우리가 주가만 보고 얘기를 해도 시가총액을 얘기하는 것과 똑같은 효과가 있다는 거죠.
주식이라는 거는 살아 움직이는 거기 때문에 그렇게 명확한 버블의 기준이라는 거는 없습니다.
사람마다 기준이 달라요.
다만 일반적으로 뭐를 얘기하냐.
시가총액이 100조라고 가정을 할게요.
1년에 1조를 벌어요.
버는데 몇 년 걸려요?
100년 걸려요.
싸 보여요? 비싸 보여요?
100년은 저 못 기다릴 것 같아요.
이게 비싸 보이잖아요.
이게 우리가 흔히 멀티풀이라고도 얘기하고 여러분들이 많이 얘기하는 PR이라고도 얘기합니다.
그런데 얘가 1년에 10조를 벌어요.
10년 걸리잖아요.
적절해요? 안 적절해요?
10년은 기다릴 수 있을 것 같습니다.
10년은 괜찮을 것 같아요?
그러면 그 사이 어딘가가 여러분들이 지금 버블에 대한 판단을 하는 겁니다.
그럼 그것도 주주가 어떻게 생각하냐에 따라서 또 다르겠네요.
그럼요. 어떤 기업은 이 소위 말해 배수가 굉장히 큰 기업들이 있어요.
테슬라.
테슬라, 스페이스X 화성 간다며?
그럼 앞으로 엄청나게 벌 거야.
그럼 앞으로는 10조가 아니라 이 기업이 100조를 벌어요.
100조를 벌 것 같아.
한 배밖에 안 되잖아요.
너무 싸.
이 가격이 막 올라가는 거죠.
소위 말해 이 회사의 어떤 비전이냐 이런 것에 따라 달라요.
그런데 어떤 회사는 공장 큰 걸 돌려.
1년에 찍는 게 정해져 있어.
이 기업은 딱 멀티풀이 딱 정해져 있죠.
그런 경우에는 이 PR이라고 부르는 멀티풀을 굉장히 높게 주기 힘들겠죠.
그러면 상장되면 꿈을 팔아야 되네요.
사기꾼 기업들이 좀.
그런 생각하면 이제 깜빡 가요.
업종에 따라서 기업 상황에 따라서 1년 버는 돈에 비해서 배수가 많이 왔다 갔다 하는데
그걸로 업종이 달라요.
그러니까ери얼과 볼륨을 가장 많이 판단을 하고
여러분들이 좋아하는 반도체 반도체는 뭘로 볼까요.
돈으로도 물론 보는데 쉽게 말하면 공장 크기로 많이 봅니다.
이게 공장 크기는 뭡니까?
쉽게 표현한 거예요.
자산이죠.
그래서 반도체는 자산 대비 시가총액이 얼마나 차이가 있냐로 많이 봐요.
이걸 소위 좀 어렵지만 PBR이라고 해요.
Book Value 한마디로 이만한 공장 있으면 거기에 대비해서 시가총액이 몇 배냐
그런 식으로 보기도 합니다.
공장이 중요한 기업은.
공장이 많으면 시가총액이 높을 수도 있겠죠.
거기에서 생산해 나가는 건 결정이 돼있으니까.
아까 액면 얘기하실 때 자본 얘기하셨는데
자본이랑 자산이랑 다른 거예요?
자산과 자본의 차이
내가 100만 원을 갖고 회사를 시작했어요.
돈이 부족해.
은행에서 대출을 받았어요.
이게 뭡니까? 빚이죠.
그래서 이걸로 차 사고, 사무실 사고 등등을 샀어요.
그래서 이렇게 된 사무실에서 이 기업이 시작합니다.
이 기업의 자산은 얼마예요?
200만 원이에요.
지금 이게 자산이잖아요.
내 자본 100만 원에다가 대출 100만 원을 더해서
차 사고, 사무실 사고, 집게 사고, 컴퓨터 사고 등등 넣은 다음에
여기서 이제 시작을 한단 말이에요.
이 기업의 자산은 200만 원입니다.
자본은 얼마예요?
100만 원이에요.
내가 돈을 막 벌어요.
그러면 50만 원을 벌었어.
그럼 여기다가 자본에다가 50만 원이 나중에 더해지고
그럼 자산은 더 커지고 자본은 더 커지고
이런 게 있는 거죠.
대출이 늘어나면 그렇고
야 유치원에 비해서 지금 중고등학교까지 넘어가잖아.
질문이 나니까
너무 어렵습니다.
끝!
감사합니다.
캔들 보죠. 캔들.
A, B, C, E가 있습니다.
시가가 어디예요?
A?
빨간지?
아닌가?
빨간색 양봉이에요?
자네 미국장 하다 왔어요.
제가 미국장 하는 곳입니다.
아 외국에서 오셨군요.
이게 소위 경매 비슷한 거예요 사실.
얼마입니까?
9,800원, 9,200원, 9,400원
어? 500원, 500원 없습니까? 없습니까?
9시 땡!
9,500원 낙찰!